and i really believe that business is
done human to human and it's about
bringing humans together
and because the community is people
all you need to do really is listen to
the people in the community and
understand their needs
[Music]
early grouper thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders good
morning
good morning thank you for having me
it's it's a pleasure and an honor to
have you here executive director of
ecomotion
the whole smart mobility space is you
know fascinating there's there's so many
advancements and there's so many things
that are happening that i can't even
keep track and when i think about
you know where we're ahead in the next
five or ten years i'm incredibly excited
you know before we even talk about your
journey and who you are
tell me a little bit about what is smart
mobility and why is it something that is
so fascinating to you
wow it's my favorite topic
um so smart mobility
is anything that is uh smarter greener
more efficient
um better and saves more
money or um
also just improved i guess
something that is smarter than before um
if we look at mobility until now
mainly used by vehicles
now we're starting to see the metro in
tel aviv and micro mobility and
bubble which is via technologies and all
these other things so
we're right now seeing this whole new
revolution that is coming
and basically i look at this revolution
kind of like
we had you know the industrial
revolution and then we had the telecom
revolution
and what i love about the telecom
revolution and this is what i compare it
um with in the mobility world
is that when we had the whole
communication era that had a lot of
investments and a lot of um
developing of technologies in this field
uh
a lot of money was thrown in in the end
we haven't we haven't seen like we
that we didn't even understand where
we're going to and we didn't understand
that we
all end up with a flat screen right um
it's something that no one
saw coming and this is like a very
given thing to us these days so mobility
for me is the same thing
there's right now a lot of investments a
lot of improvements a lot of people are
working on it from a lot of different
angles
we have no idea what the platform is but
for sure it's going to be a whole new
exciting
era for us i think that that is such an
interesting analogy the this flat screen
analogy you know what i'm thinking back
to when i was a kid you know we're
talking about 2004 2005
and we're looking at all these
advancements with the telecommunications
nobody really knew that in 2006 steve
jobs
was going to go on stage and show the
flat
iphone and the touch screen and and
really create a whole revolution in that
sense and and
and i think it's just inspiring to think
that you know we don't really know
what this iphone representation is going
to be in the in the
smart mobility space moving forwards but
orly take me back a little bit about
it to your journey how do you even get
started with smart mobility what is that
trigger
and and what have been some of your
experiences within the space
um well today you know i i see that it
goes way farther than i thought in the
beginning
because um i was always passionate about
old-fashioned vehicles
i wanted a motorcycle since i can
remember
and at the age of 15 when i really
wanted one already and i could have it
at the age of 16 i started getting
lessons
and my parents let me have lessons but
they wouldn't find me a motorcycle in
the end so it turns out i had to found
my own company
and i founded an electric motorcycle
company
but i guess uh professionally it started
um in the army in the air force
i was uh like exposed to the whole
aviation world
i was in the room of missions of an m16
squad and then commander of course and
i loved aviation and everything is
brought with it and how you know
it's crazy but we really take for
granted the thing that we
go into this vehicle yeah
even if it's a car we sit down and then
we come out on the other side
um after you know just resting for a
while
um and after the army i was recruited to
operate a private aviation place so i
continued with this passion
and i did my b
and then founded the blitz motors i sold
my half uh six years ago
uh they just ipo'd last week which is
really exciting wow
congratulations yeah it's amazing
i it's electric motorcycles you know and
every motorcycle that someone
like got off the road uh old school
petrol with the whole smoke coming out
type of
motorcycle and and putting on a new
electric
green quiet one it's like
everyone sold is like it was an amazing
amazing experience for me and i think
that's incredible orly i have to ask
about the the founding of blitz of the
of the blitz company with the electric
motorcycles
it has to be a little bit different than
starting another software company
or or you know the typical startup that
you see today that is mainly software
focused
with either b2c or b2b you're here
selling literally
vehicles that have to be certified to go
on the street they have to be safe they
have to provide some
good experience to their users tell me a
little bit about this founding of the
company
and some of the interesting challenges
that you had along the way
wow so many challenges
um well i guess it started really by
understanding what is needed
and what exists right because
um when you're doing a startup and it
doesn't matter what you do
it's okay if you start searching and you
see that other things
other things that exist um which are
the same world the same market it's okay
it means there is a market
um but you need to see how you do it
better and how you offer something that
they don't offer right it needs to be
right um in motorcycles during
motorcycles for me it was
i i saw that there's like an israel very
high power
but super expensive ones and
non-expensive ones but
not at all meeting their requirements of
the israeli rider right
they want to be on the road they need
the power and um
then i went out looking for one and we
couldn't really find one so
um we found um different
manufacturers that created different
parts and found an assembler that
assembled everything under our brand and
created this um
this vehicle a two-wheeled vehicle that
you know was at the same price
of petrol vehicles on the market but
still you were saving from day one and
it was high powered
so we gave people what they wanted and
um regarding challenges so many
wow one finding you know a manufacturer
that
would do it that would get on this
adventure a second
to get the israeli government on board
with this you know
ministry of transportation um
and then the israeli standard institute
and there's
just that as a whole it's a whole
challenge we have a lot
a lot to go uh through with easing
bureaucracy
and then it was creating a showroom in
tel aviv and creating a whole
um garages network
all over its house they could maintain
the vehicle and then you know
creating a clientele and maintaining the
thing i loved about the clients is that
they created their own
bike club like electric motorcycle
bikers club and
really moving yeah it really showed how
people were connected
i love that and i have to early i think
this is a perfect segue to
the whole community scene because your
product or the electric motorcycles
created it created some grassroots
communities that started as a result of
people buying into your product the
mission and the experience
but then you went and you intentionally
um
helped run a and still are still running
i think the biggest smart mobility
community i think over 600 startups are
involved with this community am i right
yeah over 600 startups and 12 000
community members
um because startups can't really grow
within a void we started a community
that brings together all the relevant
players so we have industry players
investors government entities
municipalities academia all-in-one
um and yeah it's amazing ecomotion
started in 2012.
um i used to be an entrepreneur uh as
part of the community you started you
know meetups were like 15 people
and um the the the guy they brought to
talk
was talking about you know innovative
design more in 2012
we weren't really talking about the
whole digitalization yet
but understanding that that's that's the
future and how israel
in this digitalization of mobility we
talked about smarter mobility before so
um digitalization is a huge part of that
um and how israel you know now has an
advantage to do that and this community
is
is amazing it's moving actually the
everyone is so engaged in creating this
better future
and really good people so it's a great
job
i love that early tell me a little bit
about building a community and running a
community
first in general the the different you
know challenges and the
things to keep in mind when building a
community but then specifically in smart
mobility and
in a growing industry that is often
perhaps misunderstood about its
potential
or it's you know still pretty you can
consider pre-iphone era
right in terms of the analogy that we
had before so what what are some of the
challenges and exhilarating factors of
running a community
um so community is people
that's what you need to understand and i
really believe that business has done
human to human and it's about bringing
humans together
and because the community is people
all you need to do really is listen to
the people in the community and
understand their needs
and then with the power of the community
and the quantity the villa
deliver those needs um and
and these these needs keep changing all
the time so you really need to be on top
of it
um we have on our team a community
manager a partnership manager we have
an implementation manager and yet when
we meet with startups the whole team
meets with them it's not like one
person's
you know job because it's really
important for me that the whole thing is
getting on top of the trend
the technology and the needs to hear the
startups all the time and to
try and pick up you know in between all
these meetings try and connect the dots
so
when i just started at a commotion for
example i heard a lot
of startups thing okay now there are so
many investors out there
in the field of mobility how do we know
who is relevant for us
and um so
we i heard this a lot of times and then
i was like okay we need to do something
so we went into this
and started speaking you know a plan and
we understood in the end that we want to
map all the investors out there
and now we have like a digital map where
um
it goes according to the different
sectors as we see them so you can see
really the logos in different techniques
and you can filter by round
so you know who's the relevant investor
for you and when you click on it you
have a whole
all the information about this investor
and who's the person to contact in the
company
so we don't need to you know connect um
and do intros and things like that the
community can meet each other but it's a
lot about
giving supporting tools for that and you
know facilitating those interactions
no no that makes perfect sense yeah
tell me a little bit though about about
investments in smart mobility are they
the same
as in a regular startup is the due
diligence process a little different
what is the thinking process when you go
and evaluate a company that is perhaps
doing something that the market is not
yet accustomed to
you may there may be not even you know
governmental supporter infrastructure
yet
but you're building a technology that
could potentially have a positive impact
well i think most governments of the
world are now you're probably talking
about autonomy so
i think most governments in the world
are now on board with this and trying to
understand how they create resolution
regulation that is supportive and not
you know
is restraining because it's it's really
hard to make up rules today
for something that you need you know
you'll only know the impact and
deployment in a few years
so um regarding investments i think
it's like many other fields the first
thing in investments is the team
so that's a really important one it
doesn't matter what field you are the
team is the first thing people look at
when they put money they put more money
on the humans than they do
on the technology and because in the end
the technology
um technology will be made by the humans
creating it
so an investor wants to know you know
that
the the the entrepreneurs will be able
to stand back up once they fall um will
be able to
you know find solutions when they'll put
a brick wall because they will many
times
and it's frustrating and domain um
but but that's i think the main focus
and um
and there's many different you know
types of mobility
uh when we look at it so you have the
whole autonomous and connected world
and in these like last
years so there's a lot of talk about
level four and five you know being
pushed back
but level two three here and now and
there's so many
so much technologies needed already for
these levels
so it shouldn't you know uh frighten
anyone
wanting to go into this field because
there's so much more to be
you know created for for that and that's
the near future
um and also i've seen really high um
a and seed round investment so a lot of
companies can really run
for for a while and um
the other things are like mobility
services so it can be an app like
movements yeah this is our mobility
today so we want to
and it could be a a kickstarter platform
like we need to remember bird and lime
and all those
were not existent like five years ago
right
it's like you think it's it's it's
mind-boggling and it's not yeah
because we don't see our life without it
now
and and think how much they're creating
that
and how much there's more to optimize
and you know the
the mobility in different countries is
not at all the same
like israel it doesn't have the great
public transportation
um where other countries do and you know
there's advantages and opportunities in
each one of those
right orly tell me a little bit about
the future of smart smart mobility from
your take
and from observing the work of hundreds
of startups
what are some of the most exciting
advancements tangibly that we can
expect to see in our streets on our
phones
satellites whatever it may be how is our
consumer behavior expected to change
realistically over the next five or ten
years
wow five or ten years okay you're
narrowing it down to more like the now
um right i think when we were feeling
the five to ten years
in the shorter version uh shorter term
is and and i'm speaking this is short
for me because you know it's um
right a lot of perhaps in the past ten
years but
but in these five to ten years i think
everything will become more seamless
um we are still buying tickets for stuff
that's not gonna happen anymore um
you're just gonna use
things and it will be added to your bill
kind of thing
um where if you know you hop on a kick
scooter
and then you get on a train you come off
and then you get on
a bus then you know all that ride will
just
too much payment um
in terms of logistics i feel uh these
five to 10 years
so what we've experienced in this whole
corona era is like
e-commerce yeah like craziness
and this affects also logistics and i
feel like logistics is going to improve
tremendously
um we're looking at you know instead of
big trucks
like taking things off the ship and
taking that into the city
um it's gonna break down into smaller
smaller packages
and more urban like logistics something
that is
more compatible with the city 100 um
yeah and who i feel this city is um
um most cities are are you know
making more walkways and uh more
bike lanes and um amsterdam was there
long ago
before us but but it really it really
shows right now that
that we're going back to this to this
era or forward to this era
um regarding the autonomy then
um i think in 10 years it
it'll be weird to you know drive a whole
a whole way from our house
to the destination um
i i can't say you know what level will
be
at and all of that i always say i'm not
a prophet
but i'm sure it will be weird you know
what i mean
i love that i love that distinction by
the way early because you're not just
saying that you know it'll be a you
it'll be common
the fact that you're saying that it'll
be weird to drive the whole way it
implies that it's not just that the
people who ride the wave are going to be
like you know the first consumers that
are going to jump into
you know like we have with tesla today
but you're saying that our consumer
behavior is going to already shift in
such a way
that it'll be odd to not have some sort
of autonomy
along your driving route perhaps you
know some people will have
full autonomy but the average person it
will be weird if they don't
only a unfortunately you know 20 minutes
go by so quickly but i really want to
thank you for for your time and for your
generosity
it goes by quick right but but i'd love
to ask you for
the most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself and i really wanted to
talk about gardening but we just didn't
have time
so we'll keep that for the next episode
yeah um three words i used to describe
myself
well um i guess i'm a child of
light love and creation that's like the
three words that guide me in life
um this is what i feel is the
true meaning to everything um wonderful
wonderful that that that sounds great
orly thank you very very much this was
fantastic thank you for the inspiration
and and stay safe and stay healthy i
can't wait to share this with the world
thank you yes thank you ciao